vous avez sûrement de la vanille oubliée
au fond de l'armoire je vais vous
présenter deux femmes qui vont vous
donner l'envie de l'utiliser au maximum
[Musique]
faut ouvrir en deux au resto malgache
tac tac la chef prépare une recette
infusée d'une gousse de vanille bien
grave
avec la pointe de son couteau elle en
extrait la partie la plus gorgée de
saveur où on appelle ça caviar de
vanille là on essaie de prendre le
maximum depuis toujours Rihanna andriam
bololona cuisine avec la vanille
aujourd'hui elle utilise cette épice
plus souvent associée au dessert dans un
plat salé
et ici vous utilisez surtout la gousse
c'est comme ça que vous travaillez au
restaurant pourquoi particulièrement la
gousse parce que la gousse a plus de
parfum tu as pas besoin d'utiliser
beaucoup
c'est les bijoux de la castafia c'est
les vanilles les plus précieuses les
plus recherchées Chantal Caron et
passionné de vanille grâce à ses
relations avec des producteurs locaux
elle parcourt le monde à la recherche
des variétés de vanille les plus fines
quand les vanilles sont à ce point
matures bien travaillé par les
producteurs il y a tant de véniles à
l'intérieur que sa cristallise tout le
tour
il y a rien de plus noble il y a rien de
plus fascinant qu'une plante qui met
neuf mois à naître depuis ce qu'on
appelle le mariage en malgache le
mariage c'est à dire la pollinisation
jusqu'au fruits mur 9 mois plus tard il
faut savoir c'est une c'est une orchidée
qui est pollinisée manuellement et au
bout de 9 mois on a un fruit qui doit
être traité avec beaucoup beaucoup
d'heures faut pas penser que ce produit
là échappe pour rien il y a un travail
immense derrière ça
selon la variété une gousse de vanille
peut coûter de 1 à 5 dollars
la gousse de vanille doit mûrir quelques
mois et ensuite le processus d'affinage
peut durer jusqu'à deux ans alors voici
une qualité exceptionnelle de vanille de
Madagascar de la région de Mananara Nord
c'est la variété la plus pâtissière
c'est celle que les pâtissier
recherchent pour la souplesse pour un
une gousse qui grasse qui facilitent à
manipuler quand on l'ouvre quand on va
chercher le caviar on gratte ça sort
comme du beurre
Madagascar est le plus gros producteur
de vanille on en produit aussi dans
certains pays d'Amérique du Sud et
d'Afrique en Indonésie et à Tahiti
notamment
la vanille est l'une des épices les plus
prisées au monde c'est qu'elle contient
de la vanille un puissant à Jean
aromatique qui rehausse une quantité de
recettes
pour sa recette de saumon rihanna fait
infuser une gousse et notre trésor va
nulle une technique qui permet d'en
extraire un maximum d'arômes combien de
temps on laisse infuser la vanille dans
la crème oh c'est très rapide c'est très
rapide
la chef utilise ses goss moins fraîche
pour les réduire en poudre
certains commerces spécialisés en
offrent aussi cette poudre peut être
simplement saupoudrée sur des tartes ou
infuser dans du lait ou de la crème pour
en faire des desserts par exemple pour
faire le foie gras la vanille Madagascar
j'utilise plus ça que la gousse parce
que c'est très facile à en mettre
partout pour remplacer la gousse on peut
utiliser l'extrait de vanille une
macération dans l'alcool qui se trouve
et s'emploie facilement pour parfumer
des sauces ou des préparations à
pâtisserie la pâte de vanille nouvelle
sur le marché canadien est très
polyvalente gorgée de sucre et de
saveurs elle peut être utilisée pour
fabriquer ou garnir du yogourt de la
crème glacée ou des crêpes
c'est fait avec la gousse entière on y
trouve le caviar en abondance et les
locaviars et bien suspendus bien
distribués dans le produit ce qui fait
qu'on va par exemple faire une crème
glacée voir les petits grains en
suspension partout en plus il y a pas
d'alcool dedans donc l'avantage
d'acheter une pâte comme celle-là plutôt
que la gousse c'est qu'on a pas à faire
la manipulation dans un tire-lait
pour les petits budgets l'extrait
artificiel de vanille est composé d'eau
d'arômes de colorant et d'alcool mais ne
contient aucune trace de vanille
peu importe sous quelle forme on la
consomme le goût de la vanille se
décline selon différents terroirs
[Musique]
une goutte dans un café dans un thé dans
une pâtisserie puis on a toute cette
puissance là alors ici on a celle de
Madagascar on a de la prune de la figue
et au goût là on commence à goûter un
peu plus le fruit on a des notes de cuir
on a des notes de tabac dedans qu'est-ce
qui vous fait triper tant que ça dans la
vanille
c'est physique
mais j'avoue que c'est vrai qu'un petit
quelque chose d'euphorisant dans le
parfum dans le goût ça prend du temps
avant de pouvoir dire tout ce qui se
passe en bouche il y a tellement de
saveurs on fait un heure je pense à la
vanille aujourd'hui avec vous merci
beaucoup
[Musique]